hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff hope you're all having a
great sunday because i will try to
improve it at least a little bit further
uh it is of course the 1858 match
between paul charles morphy and otto
thunders in the greatest chess match of
the 19th century that took place in 1858
in paris uh and so far we've checked out
seven games accidentally in the previous
video i've shown game eight prior to
game seven so i'm only showing game
seven now but uh you know yeah all in
all nothing has been spoiled and you
know the the the match still continues
in in a great way uh because this is the
first first one to seven wins draws not
counting and since the game eight ended
in a draw i haven't really ruined
anything for you but still uh sorry
about that uh so uh this one is again a
really really fun game and it really
shows a lot about the the state that
anderson is currently in being down so
many points uh in the match and i've
used this quote from david bronstein
saying that a game of chess is not an
examination of knowledge it is a battle
of nerves and while this holds true for
for a chess game uh even more so i would
say for a chess match so that being said
let's check out the game and see what
happened what's happening in this one
morphe again with the white pieces opens
with e4 and now anderson returns to his
scandinavian defense and goes for d5 he
already tried it once uh now he's going
to try it again but with a very
different line so he captures on the e5
and now he grabs the pawn in the
previous game if you remember knight to
f6 was played so queen captures on d5
knight to c3 and i even made a video on
a really fun line of the scandinavian
defense that i enjoy playing if you
still haven't seen it do check it out i
will put a link into it the first thing
you will see in the description below uh
you know a fun way to try the
scandinavian defense so usually there's
queen d8 there's queen to a5 and the
video i'm talking about i i analyze
queen to d6 which is my favorite here
but okay queen to a5 uh even our good
friend yohanyako blue intel agrees that
this is not a great attempt with black
so queen day five keeping the queen
active uh is definitely the way to go
uh d4 morphe occupies the center with a
pawn and now e5 this is the so-called
anderson counter attack
in this line of the scandinavian as you
see uh
anderson's name pops out in pretty much
every opening and every line that
we use because well he was uh just so
influential during his lifetime so the
characters on e5 we have queen captures
on e5 with check morphy plays bishop to
e2 and now anderson develops with temple
he plays bishop to b4 now the thread is
captures captures and of course captures
uh he wants to win a pawn uh but the
morphe doesn't defend with bishop to b2
morphy says you can have your pawn uh
i'm all about the development knight to
f3 now attacking anderson's queen and
there really isn't nothing anything
better here you have to accept the gift
bishop captures on c3 was played b
captures queen captures on c3 with check
also attacking the rook so you have to
play bishop to d2 uh bishop to d2 now
the queen is defending the rook and
anderson goes back queen to c5 and now
rook to b1 and you can see for the price
of this one pawn morphy has all of these
pieces nicely developed whereas anderson
only has a queen out and that's not not
a sign of a great attacker so knights
the c6 anderson has to hurry and start
developing his pieces we have castles
and now knight to f6 and this position
now uh has never been reached again so
uh it is now as of 11 that we have a
completely new game uh and now morphe
plays bishop to f4 he says all right you
can castle i'm going to win back my pawn
and we just continue playing while i'm a
little bit ahead in development so
nothing serious here black is perfectly
fine
anderson castles there's really no
way of defending this pawn and now
morphy goes after the pawn if morphe
wanted he could play rook to b5 and you
know keep it very active uh
not trying to claim his pawn back a bit
too soon and after queen e7 defending
the pawn uh even rook to e1 uh placing
the rook on the e file as the queen is
on e7 later on maybe we can play bishop
to d3 and there there also may be one
way to play this but uh morphy says no
let's not overcomplicate let's play
bishop captures on c7 and here he gives
unders quite a lot of moves anderson can
play rook to e8 he could play knights to
e4 he could play uh knights the d for uh
a lot a lot of a lot of options here but
the move understand place uh maybe
allows morphy to well just uh
keep it to keep it too simple and not
allow anderson to go for any
complications so knights the e4 maybe is
the way to go here after knights to e4
you're threatening knight the c3 of
forking the rook the queen the bishop so
maybe knight to the e4 that would be
great here but anderson played knight to
d4 and morphe very happily captured this
knight queen captures on d4 anderson
grabbed the bishop
and now bishop to d3 morphy just places
the bishop on this long diagonal as the
bishop wasn't really doing all that much
on e2 and now bishop the g for trying to
capture here and mess up morphy's pawn
structure but now just knight to g5 now
this knight can't really move uh you're
going to lose the h7 pawn if you do this
you could play h6 right away but then
knights the e4 and well this is this is
very good for white if you captured in
queen captures you have some checkmating
threats so maybe not the the greatest
way to chase off this knight so here
anderson plays rook after d8 attacking
morphy's queen and morphy moves it with
tempo queen before attacking the b7 pawn
and you can't really defend it our good
friend johan jacob blumenthal even gives
the following line as how to
defend incorrectly if you play b6 and
try to defend this way we're just gonna
play knight captures on h7 and uh
there's not uh much you can do if uh you
can't capture with the king the knights
defended if you capture with the knight
then queen captures bishop here and we
won the h7 pawn instead of the b7 pawn
but we're winning upon
one thing that anderson could do here if
he was uh you know really eager to keep
it an active game he could play h6 now
uh point being that now after the knight
moves uh let's say uh we're gonna go
knights to e4 anderson plays knight to
d7 avoids a trait here and after
morphing grabs upon he can play knight's
queen to f4 and uh keep in active
position he would be down a pawn but i
mean that should not be a problem for
anderson he should bring the uh knight
to the e5 maybe maybe try and do some
sort of a rook lift here it's not going
to be easy with the knight guarding f6
and bishop x-raying the g6 square but
you know it's it's a start
but anderson already being so much down
in the match uh decides to retreat with
bishop to c8 and this is a really sad
move that
when you have to make it disconnecting
the rooks like this uh
going back instead of going forward not
not a move that you know is consistent
with anderson's nature uh but okay uh
rook f the e1 uh morphe not rushing
anything bishop to c4 is possible going
after f7 but uh just rook to d7 defends
this so morphy says your rooks are
disconnected let's play rook f to e1 and
now anderson has to be very very careful
here for example if you try to chase
away the knight like this with h6 now
rook to a7 is just extremely strong here
attacking the queen and after queen to
d6 trying to trade off the queens now
we're very happily gonna do this
captures captures and now we don't even
have to capture on f7 right away we can
play rook to e1 and you know white's
position is just much better we're going
to capture on f7 next and there's not
much black can do about this uh of
course if you capture the knight then we
give up the rook and it's checkmate the
bishop still covers the h7 square so uh
there there was only one possible moment
to play h6 and it was um at that time
where where anderson should have
sacrificed the b 7.4 activity here uh
he's still going to lose material and he
you know is a very very passive so i
don't know uh it doesn't seem like
anderson is playing this game you know
with his full strength or morphe just
has this effect on all of the opponents
that he faces so here anderson plays a5
attacks morphy's queen now morphy says
all right i could play pretty much
anything here but i'm gonna play queen
e7 and trade queens my position is just
better so why not understand traits here
there's really not much else you could
do f7 is being threatened so queen
captures here we have rook captures on
e7 and now
again f7 being threatened not much for
you to do here
anderson tries one very tricky move
knight to d5 he attacks the rook but he
uh allows morphe to capture on h7 and
morphy of course does bishop captures on
h7 you have to play king to h8 if you go
to f8 it's a very easy checkmate rook
capture sun f7 king to e8 and now rook
to e1 check and there are no squares for
the king you have to block and then this
will just be checkmate so after bishop
captures an h7 anderson forced to go to
the h8 square and now rook captures an
f7 more morphic grabbing more material
and there's not much you can do here
knights to c3 attacking the rook and the
pawn here anderson has to win back some
material at least but now rook to e1 we
have knight captures on a2 and now
morphy's position is completely winning
there are a lot of winning moves here
but uh you know that just for fun feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find the way that morphe ended the game
while i give you a couple of seconds
uh for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on finding this uh uh
idea it is in fact the strongest move
recommended by the engine and if you
found it i'm i have no doubt that this
will greatly improve your sunday uh and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it is rook to f4
this is the move that morphe played you
could play rook to f3 it's not a problem
but rook to f4 is you know uh on an
engine uh scale of precision is a bit
more precise and this is of course what
morphe played uh and here there's really
not much you can do uh the rook is
coming to h4 and that's it there there's
no defending the position uh anderson
played one more move he played rook to
a6 trying to maybe somehow shift the
uh the rook over here uh but morphy
doesn't even rush with some like knight
to f7 check uh or you can't rush because
the bishop is hanging he just brings the
bishop back bishop to d3
this comes with tempo and now the h7
square is off limits to the black king
the rook is under attack and there's no
no more moves here for anderson uh so it
was in this position on move 25 that
otto thunderson resigned in the game and
yet another victory for paul charles
morphy
so here you resign because well if you
try rook to h6 we already said that this
is just a monster fork uh forking the
both of the rooks and the king there's
nothing you can do here and if you try
something weird like rook captures on d3
trying to give up uh the you know the
exchange uh this is just mate in one uh
or rather you could even play uh rook to
f8 would mate in what as the knight also
covers the h7 square
uh so yeah really impressive stuff by
morphe uh anderson uh gave him uh you
know uh some chances but unlike anderson
in the previous game morphe uh really
nicely exploited all of the chances and
you know just crush anderson here in a
very short game in in 25 moves so tough
position for anderson uh after eight
games that were played um you all know
if you've been following so far uh
anderson started with a win then they
drew the second game morphe retaliated
in the third game and then morphe got
four wins in a row
up until game eight and then
there was another draw because we
already have shown game 18 in the
previous video so understand down a lot
in the match and it will be very
interesting to see what he will attempt
to to come back and will he gain at
least one more win against morphy or
maybe he's going to equalize we'll see
what happens i mean we're still
very early on in the in the morphe saga
so
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
and congratulations to everyone who
successfully improved their sunday uh i
would like to thank tom derelo nti in
new orleans pablo mohan richard yarnell
and michael sprog for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga until it ends
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day